this rusty fishing boat made slow
progress against the tide on the final
leg of a long trip down river but the
sesimbra and her crew hadn't caught any
fish instead they were saving people's
lives
up on deck were residents from Busey a
town that's been badly damaged by the
floods
the crew began to unload their
passengers on a coastal beach offering
relative safety the babies and the
children went first
many were sick and weak from hunger
after days without food and clean water
their parents were anxious and
desperately tired telling us they'd lost
everything they owned to the cyclone and
break up our houses some plates float
away a place where we were living was
gone with the winter
we climbed up on deck as the evacuees
inched their way down and found a man
worrying about the people he'd left
behind he said there are thousands in
boozy still stranded on the rooftops
agenda status in the Azul de it was a
difficult experience many people still
need help they're living on the tops of
their houses like I was by the grace of
God I survived
there was nobody from the government or
the aid agencies to greet them and their
rescue was performed by volunteers like
the boats humble captain who taken
matters into his own hands why did you
feel like you had to assist we are human
beings that's why we're doing it I mean
you could be making money right now you
could be out you could be fishing but
you're not sitting a door you must put
people's lives ahead of money they left
the beach in barrer in search of food
and clean water holding their worldly
possessions aloft
for those injured or ill there were
people willing to help them nearby if
they were able to find this field clinic
we are in the middle of the mid morning
rush this is where people who are sick
and injured who are hungry who have lost
all their possessions including their
clothes this is where they come although
we're not exactly sure how they get here
we're about one kilometer away from from
the main beach but they are here and
they're getting help and that's a good
thing
medics from the Indian Army treated
infected feet and battered shoulders
while the Red Cross handed out cups of
soup for many it was the first meal in
days we're feeling safe now who said
this woman they couldn't wait any longer
and made the decision to flee in a
region where vast areas are under water
it was an act of courage that may have
kept them alive John sparks Sky News
Barrow